haha oh yeah I saw you on there the
other night it's funny yeah I meant to
tell you that is not a good profile
picture of you you are way hotter in
real life uh that's funny cuz we a match
yeah I swipe left what why because Kate
what oh you're such a catch Kate
they would be lucky to have me nice man
I still mean that I just what do you
think that I'm undateable or do you
think you're just that much better oh
wow
you there relax or whatever and put on
your freakin Sunday best buddy because
I'm gonna date the [ __ ] out of you
tonight
it is a wildly bad idea for two best
friends to date kind of sounds like
you're scared
that's great date me scared of all in
love well first of all I am not scared
it sounds like what you're saying is you
don't think I could date you I don't
think you could close the deal you
better get your little [ __ ] me flat on
honey
cuz I'm gonna take all of this out
tonight great yeah
get ready to fall in love I will not sir
I really take you down well you would go
down on me
second whooping you're all out great
just explain are idiot earned it is the
last night of your life buddy but wait
you were me
remember the pusses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mind if I join you
what the [ __ ] are you wearing
oh look at that it's the 94 Mall back
it's gonna the fruity zoanoids good I'm
sorry my apologies my condolences to the
white would you listen otherwise yeah
you put on my tab really I don't mind I
don't mind at all
totally fine um so earlier I was reading
about modern look like I'm mine
I am sophisticated dating or as the
Romans would call it sophisticated no
you know what I am NOT gonna do this
because you were acting do ya stop
breaking the illusion I'm not your
frickin best friend right now okay I'm
being what I am on a date so whatever
you are on a demons you just beeped at
okay okay fine ruin my old flow sorry
why don't you guys just be yourselves no
no here's three three twelve
yeah you can't be yourself on a date
notifies the table your target I'll be
right there
right behind you if you come here for a
second listen to me I am about to order
a garden salad okay thank you two
premium grilled cheese by mistake okay
and I won't send it back because I won I
want it buttered so hard and the butter
drips right through every crevice and
riyals the cheese do you want taken
that's good that's good you do this
might be a little bit of a surprise in
there for you okay get it thank you so
much so we were driving up to the
mountain or we'll try for a two wheel
drive I don't know anything about cars
oh thank you so much
let's dive in Shirley and I do believe
you're in the middle of a story what I
was saying was that this is an
incredible hey Kate Kate we can't date
Billy you've seen me [ __ ] on the side of
the road before
remember that time I puked in my own
purse actually I think I might have been
your purse point is we're too close are
you looking at me like that huh what
nothing
I'm here you know okay I'll be honest
with you cats out of the bag I'm hearing
you and I think that maybe you're a
little intimidated right now and I think
that maybe you if you wanted to bow out
you do that and I would never bring it
up again having a really good time great
and I'm digging this and yeah I'm gonna
go ahead and a piggyback off of what you
were saying I feel like if me and the
rock hi remember that time you helps me
get not one but two tampons out of my
vagina do you still really want to date
me what's wrong no I'm totally fine you
sure yeah as a matter of fact I know
that you crumble under pressure like her
a grumbler so I I don't come a little
[ __ ] i entice try to keep your pants on
after this one oh wow we're at it round
she goes that's your move
whoa and then I don't need to make your
nipples hard but this works ten out of
ten times whoops
oh no what's that like there was up me
my little hot shoulder just splits
myself off you can't really forward but
my boobs keep like hitting my salad
they're just so big and full and eating
me teeth mmm better for this bread oh
wow okay Dover they don't think you're
gonna cut yourself okay okay so you know
what just get right to it why delay the
inevitable or it let's do the next
logical thing that's order us to make a
pro and con run out with each other
because you know what you're cool with
it I'm cool with it you seem like you
kiss on the first date right you're such
a good dealer I do please get ready to
me your hand doing it what you want
Oh mint I'm doing it alright not wait
this is the way oh yeah I know too much
about where you've been what kind of
kiss who you are and I haven't even kiss
you your bad kisser Wow it's not you
it's just how much about you I know ya
know like I would so [ __ ] you if I
didn't know yet I feel additionally I
owe you an apology I know I put on this
turtleneck and you got caught huge con I
couldn't yeah I mean I would never date
so I wanted a John like let's if you're
gonna pick someone else to be a someone
more in your wheelhouse you know like
Mother Goose or uh Ellen DeGeneres or
who's that one girl from that old show
with the hair help me out here Jimmy you
all get work he me giver with the fun
[Music]